okay dr. Anthony foul she and other
health officials testified yesterday
before the Senate there were a bunch of
high jinks including Senator Rand Paul
getting into an argument with dr. Falchi
Texas so disliked doctor foul she's
testimony that last night lieutenant
governor in Texas Dan Patrick went on
Fox News and said we're not going to
listen to doctor foul anymore but if you
ask me I'm listening to foul chew before
I'm listening to Dan Patrick from Texas
any day so what did doctor foul he tell
us some of the things he said were
obvious number one doctor foul she said
we are not really doing that well we are
clearly not in control of the virus and
we could have 100,000 cases a day in the
United States if things don't turn
around here he is saying it it is going
to be very disturbing I will guarantee
you that because when you have an
outbreak in one part of the country even
though in other parts of the country
they're doing well they are vulnerable I
made that point very clearly last week
at a press conference we can't just
focus on those areas that are having the
surge it puts the entire country at risk
we are now having 40-plus thousand new
cases a day I would not be surprised if
we go up to a hundred thousand a day if
this does not turn around and so I am
very concerned so this has already
gotten so bad in at least 16 states that
they've paused or reversed some aspects
of the reopening plans the hardest for
the four hardest hit States recently in
terms of cases are Florida Arizona Texas
in California now if you look at growth
rate of cases rather than absolute
numbers you actually see some other
states that are not getting a lot of
attention in terms of percentage growth
each day they are climbing and if the
trend doesn't reverse in 15 or so days
you would have a very different set of
states that is the worst in the country
in terms of new cases and again the the
message is we could just be at the
beginning here if you look at the total
numbers we cumulatively have
scene 2.7 million coronavirus cases in
the United States if the 16 states that
are problematic keep increasing their
rate of new cases just even 10% a week
which is we've seen much faster
increases and than that that 2.7 million
number in terms of cumulative cases is
going to go up dramatically and very
very quickly you can run the numbers
yourself if you look at 15 if you if we
get to 15,000 cases a day in Florida
10,000 a day in Texas in California you
start seeing that these numbers are
going to add up
insanely quickly but the administration
has moved on I mean they're the Trump
administration is just done they are
talking about reopening they're talking
about return to greatness they're
talking about jobs and stocks and all of
this other stuff we are having the work
of the four worst the four worst days
that we've had since the beginning in
terms of new cases happen in the last
five days understand that and
hilariously or tragically or I don't
even know what to call it at this point
one of trumps own hotels failed a
coronavirus hygiene audit there's these
rules in terms of hotels of how they're
supposed to be cleaning surfaces are
supposed to be wiped down all of these
different rules Trump International in
Manhattan was one of the hotels that
Inside Edition audited now you know
Inside Edition it's sort of like pseudo
News but to the extent that they're
telling the truth about this they had a
correspondent check in two rooms
including at Trump's Hotel print the
programs logo the Inside Edition logo on
the bed sheets and pillowcases and
towels using a washable spray and you
can only see that the the spray under
ultraviolet light but if the product is
washed or wiped down then it goes away
and then the Inside Edition
correspondent would make it look like
someone slept in the room they would
leave check out check back in and go
back to the same room the following
night so new as far as the hotel knows
this is a new customer a new guest there
should have been a full cleaning done
International reportedly changed the
bedsheets did not change the pillowcase
at all did not wipe down the desk and
other surfaces so clearly the Trump
hotels are not the only ones that are
failing to meet the hygiene requirements
and things are looking very very ugly in
a lot of these industries but many
states are just full steam ahead so at
this point if we ask ourselves like
where is the ray of hope where where is
the possibility it's really in the
medical field and governor's we have to
hope that governor's will show
leadership although many of them are not
we have to hope that people will take
this more seriously than they've been
mean it's been months but still a lot of
people aren't taking this seriously and
we are putting a lot of emphasis on the
medical science community that they will
develop an effective treatment something
that's better than just you know 15%
improvement for only the sickest
patients and a vaccine and we're really
waiting on that at this point because
our country has failed now I want to
remind you next I'm going to talk about
parts of the US that are doing well but
there are countries that have dominated
this I spoke to a friend who lives in
Belgium and is currently in France on a
vacation with her boyfriend things are
great there I mean on public transit
everybody's wearing masks restaurants
are open with fewer tables indoors even
outdoors life has resumed very few cases
now they are doing it and I'm I'm
envious of that I admit it fortunately
here in Massachusetts things are going
well but we are judged by the worst of
our country we are not allowed to travel
to many parts of the world because as a
country we are failing and particularly
with people able to come in and out of
states because that's the Constitution
I'm not denying that we we have to talk
next about the states that are doing
well how long can they actually hold on
because the worse things get in some
parts of the country eventually it's
going to bleed into the states that are
taking this very seriously so let's
discuss that next